alors Philippe Charlier vous allez nous
faire visiter cette exposition qui
s'appelle miroire du temps les momies de
Randazzo oui Randazzo c'est Randazzo
c'est la la ville située sur les pentes
de l'na où ont été retrouvé toutes ces
momies il y a à peu près 3 ans et donc
du coup elles ont fait l'objet d'un
d'une étude à la fois historique et
médicale comme des qui date de
l'éruption de l'EN alors en
faitenna plutôt ça date de plusieurs
éruptions de l'eetna ell schon entre le
17e et le 19e siècle et elles ont été
déposées initialement dans une église et
puis oublié au fur et à mesure du temps
en muré et puis voilà on en a fait une
étude médicale c'était le sujet thè
d'une de mes étudiantes et formable et
c'est maintenant un sujet d'exposition
cette première vitrine vous montre que
la mamification n'est pas spécifique au
monde égyptien et que à peu près tout le
monde sur terre était embomumé à un
certain moment vous avez ici une momie
factice d'ibis ici des fragments de
momie de chat qui étaient embomummés
donc ce n'est pas qu'une momification
humaine ici un masque de cartonnage donc
c'est ce qui recouvrait la momie son
sarcophage et puis ici une main de momie
qui a été ins intéressante parce qu'elle
nous a servi de témoin quand on
cherchait à confronter les fausses
reliques de jeune d'c conservé à Chinon
avec des momies égyptiennes car c'était
les fausses momies de jeun qui étaient
des momies égyptiennes de chat et
humaines c'est ça alors oui on a dit
d'ailleurs que vous aviez analysé des
autres chat ou oui c'est ça oui oui tout
à fait confronté en fait c'était un un
chat de du Proche Orient et puis du du
du bitum qui recouvrait tous ces restes
là qui était tout à fait contemporain et
même nature que que celle-ci donc les
momis tout le monde passe à Égypte mais
il y en avait un petit peu partout et
notamment il y en avait en Europe au
Moyen-Âge puisque vous avez ici ce qui
était contenu à l'intérieur du ventre
d'agè Sorel ce sont les produits embom
qui ont permis la très bonne
conservation du corps d'agès Sorel donc
agè S c'est quoi c'est le mercure ça
c'est alors elle est Mor elle est morte
intoxiqué au mercure elle mais ça n'est
pas le mercure qui a été utilisé pour
l'embom pour l'embomé c'était est
utilisé pour l'embom ça c'est utilisé
pour l'embomement c'était ce qui
farcissait si je peux dire entre
guillemets son corps du thin du
gingembre du romarin de la menthe du
poivre gris maniguette et cetera et ça
sent bon toujours ça sent divinement bon
là c'est derrière la vitrine je peux
malheureusement pas vous faire respirer
mais ça sent très bon ça sent une odeur
de cuisine comme si vous c'est pour ça
que le mot farcissement n'est pas n pas
une moquerie en pratique les premiers
avir embaumé ce sont les cuisiniers
parce que ce sont eux qui savent ouvrir
la viande comme on ouvre les cadavres ce
sont eux qui ont à disposition tous les
aromates pour voilà tout tout ce que
vous faites quand vous faites un bouquet
garni par exemple ici une mèche de
cheveux d'une momie péruvienne et là une
momie artificielle non pardon naturelle
au contraire naturelle puisque c'est un
singe qui a été retrouvé dans une double
cloison il vient de notre institut
médico légal et ben à l'origine les
policiers qui sont tombés dessus n'ont
pas très bien su si c'était un bébé ou
si c'était un animal faut dire qu'il est
assez assez un petit peu déformé et
desséché c'est évidemment un animal on
voit ici sa queue et puis les mains et
les pieds qui sont assez semblable c'est
un petit s donc même dans des conditions
très particulières de dessèchement et
bien il peut y avoir une momification
naturelleification c'est ça oui c'est
pas personne n momifi un c'était pas
très intéressant et donc là vous voyez
la représentation de la tête embomée
de qui pour le coup était une mie
artificielle mais on va dire que
l'embomur avait été un tout petit peu
aidé par ravayak puisque la le pass
si je peux dire va été saigné ah oui
donc ça facilite et oui ça le dessèche
complètement il perd au moins 4 l de
sang du coup ça lui fait autant
d'humidité en moins et du coup le corps
se se dessèche et se conserve encore
mieux donc les momies de randazo ont été
trouvés en 2008 en pratique de façon for
suite dans cette église de basalt et ce
sont des restes qui sont assez bien
conservés puisqu'on a pas que des
crânnes on a également de des fragments
corporels à part entière avec de la peau
des oreilles souvent percé d'ailleurs au
niveau des lobes chez les hommes et puis
des restes dieux des restes de poils
cheveux homme plat et cetera donc
c'était des momies à l'origine qui était
présenté dans l'Église comme un sorte de
méomori les gens de l'élite payaient
pour être conservés et pour servir
d'exemple pour dire grosso modo voilà
nous nous avons été des nantis nous
avons bien mangé bien bu nous sommes
bien amusés nous avons acquis d'ailleurs
des maladies honteuses il y a un cphilis
là-bas que je vous montrerai voilà donc
nous avons bien voilà l'exist vie
l'existance sur terre éta plutôt sympa
mais retenez que maintenant nous sommes
morts et vous serez voilà nous avons été
ce que vous êtes n privilégé voilà on
est on est des cadavres comme les autres
exactement et du coup les Capucins
étaient en charge de ce processus
d'embaummement et ces corps étaient
suspendus à des Cros de bouchée dans
l'église pour servir d'exemple tout
simplement et puis passer un certain
temps ils commençaient à s'abîmer on le
voit ici hein ils sont quand même un
petit peu abîmés et ils finissaient sous
la forme d'un amoncellement de crâne
comme ce ce mur de crâne que vous voyez
ici d'accord alors heureusement ça nous
permet encore pas mal de diagnostic ou
c'est vrai que enfin c'est ce c'est un
lieu commun mais c'est vrai que quand on
est c dans cet étatl tout le monde est
égal on est tous égau qu on est tous
égau mais là là vousession vous avez
l'impression que tous les crânnes sont
pareils sauf que c'est pas vrai ils sont
al à mon à mon œil à mon œil médical ils
sont tous différents vous en avez avec
des coulures de jus de putréfaction vous
avez des enfants vous avez des adultes
vous avez des femmes des hommes vous
avez même des individus qui viennent de
l'étranger ici vous avez un crame qu'on
appelle entre guillemets négroïde donc
au moins quelqu'un qui qui vient de
l'Amérique Afrique du Nord pardon sinon
Afrique
septentrionale donc voilà on a vraiment
des migrations de population et puis des
des maladies qui sont extrêmement
diverses alors une question qui est un
peu annexe mais au 19e siècle une grande
mode de la de la mesure des crânes la
chronologie enfin bonant fait plus
maintenant mais on disait les gens plus
intelligents ont des crânes plus gros
que les autres et tout ça on a jamais
montré ça ah non non j'en suis j'en suis
l'exemple même j'ai un gros j'ai un gros
Crâ je vous avz un arr arrê
gros je Seris pas faire et puis certains
aussi font l'objet de d'autres processus
par exemple ici vous avez un individu
qui a été Sillé en fait c'est un sillage
du crâne pour deux raisons ici et là
sachant que cette voûe là ne va pas sur
cette base de crâci donc on a deux
individus différents soit ils ont été
embaumés par un processus un petit peu
particulier qui est celui du sillage du
crâne on retire le cerveau on met des
aromates à la place soit deuxème possib
mais ça se faisait pas trop à cette
périodeel la deuxième possibilité à
laquelle je crois beaucoup plus c'est
plutôt celle d'un d'une autopsie les
gensl ont été autopsiés pour connaître
la cause de mort cerveau et cetera donc
vous je pense que voilà l'autopsie
elle date de de alors l'autopsie
l'autopsie scientifique ou dissection
anatomique on la pratique au moins
depuis l'Antiquité grecque on sait que
vers 200 300 avant Jésus-Christ
Alexandrie elle avait déjà court
d'accord on regardait déjà de quoi les
gens de quoi les gens mourient ou du
moins on découpait les corps pour mieux
connaître l'anatomie humaine mais
l'autopsie médicollégale
elle prend surtout son essence déjà dans
l'antiquité greco-romaine on pouvait
ouvrir des corps o son des lesplay pour
connaître un petit peu de quoi étaient
morts les gens mais c'est surtout à
partir du 16e siècle sous charlequin que
metî vraiment l'anthropologie médico
légale et en France avec ambroiss paré
toujours le même alors on utilise on va
pas citer de marque mais un petit peu
tout ce qu'on trouve dans la cuisine est
utilisé dans les momies voilàine du sel
de la muscade du poivre alors poivre
vert et poivre noir de l'estragon et
cetera tout est et du laurier bien sûr
tout est utilisé pour on va dire
favoriser la bonne odeur sur les corps
morts tout simplement on sait maintenant
à quoi ça sert que du Cros des
carcasses je sais pas si c'est une très
bonne publicité en revanche et puis
parfois c'est extraordinaire parce que
c'est vrai que voilà c'est des produits
oui qu'on trouve chez soi aujourd'hui
enfin bon même si éta naturel qu on les
utiliser c'est c'est drôle ah c'est il y
a vraiment une grande une grande
antiquité de l'utilisation de ces
produits là et c'est toujours
intéressant c'est pour ça que je
travaille avec des nez de parfumeurs qui
eux sont à même d'identifier en
respirant ses corps quelle substance a
pu les parfumer ou de quelle substance
ils ont pu être en ça c'est très
étonnant parce que vous avez une
démarche extrêmement scientifique et
tout ça puis tout d'un coup vous faites
appel à des né de parfumeurs c'est
scientifique c'est toujours aussi
scientifique vous savez leur nez est un
nez extrêmement perfessionné et
scientifique et ensuite cette
information là elle est doublée de toute
façon par une autre information qui est
celle des nez chimiques on va dire les
bien sûr les recoup exactement voilà et
puis il y a aussi d'autres cas où
l'individu est un petit peu pathologique
et où il faut il demande malgré tout sa
sa conservation celui-ci voyez éta à la
ch donc vraisemablement il est mort
d'une maladie infectieuse il a été
d'abord désinfecté et ensuite on
désinfecte à la ch et ensuite on l' on
l'a présenté sous une forme forcément un
petit peu altérée d'autres aussi
s'abîment au cours de leur séjour dans
la dans l'église et on est obligé sur
des phases de fracture de les consolider
et de mettre un petit peu de la bourre
végétale pour les dessécher ou pour les
leur rendre une bonne odeur donc ceuxl
vous voyez ont été restaurés en parti
pendant leur séjour dans l'église
pendant leur présentation et puis vous
vous en avez d'autres voyez qui sont
maintenus par les ficelles d'autres qui
sont mangés en partie par les insectes
et puis vous en avez qui sont
extrêmement bien préservés comme
celui-ci avec son nez est encore présent
une bonne dentition et puis celui-ci qui
est mort d'une mort assez violente
puisque vous voyez qu'il a pris un coup
deblement d'épée au niveau de la nuque
ça au moins on est sûr que c'est pas un
accident c'est vraiment soit soit un
homicide soit un combat enfin un combat
ou peut-être oui peut-être une militaire
en effet ah ça c'est formidable ça et
puis vous avez aussi des témoignages
alors de maladies infectieuses là vous
avez deux dents avec des absès
extrêmement importants qui ont pu être
voyez le trou ici avec la dent perdue
pareil là avec un aspect complètement
remanié de l'os au contact ce sont des
absès dentaires dont on sait maintenant
qu' l'absence de traitement antibiotiqu
qui peuvent être à l'origine d'une
septicémie ou d'une encéphalite ou d'une
méingite en tout cas ça peut aller
extrêmement vite et provoquer la mort du
sujet et puis là vous avez comme comme
vous avez tiqué en effet ce sont deux
trépanations trpation ou alors les ces
deux individus ont survécu un homme et
une femme vraisemablement ont survécu
celui-ci un petit peu moins longtemps
puisque vous voyez que les bords ont
cicatrisé mais pas la totalité de la
surface osseuse en revanche alors que
celui-là voilà le trou était rebouché
presque voilà donc là on a quelques mois
de survie et là quelques années incro de
survie ah oui on peut déduire de ça
voilà le temps de la survie de exement
et puis la la le geste est sûr alors en
revanche qu'on ignore c'est un peu
dommage c'est frustrant exactement ce
sont les raisons pourquoi ces gens-là
ont été alors vraisemblement celle-ci
voyez elle a une autre maladie qui est
juste en arrière cet aspect un petit peu
inflammatoire juste sous le le lambout
de peau et je pense que elle elle avait
des des tumeur cutané qui finissaiit par
infiltrer ce qu'on appelle des basos
cellulaires ce sont des petites tumeurs
qui sont assez fréquentes chez des gens
qui sont souvent en ensoleillement et et
quand c'est au niveau du crâne ça peut
parfois attaquer l'os et on sait depuis
cels donc on est vraiment dans
l'antiquité romaine que lorsque ça
grignote le crâne et bien il faut
découper un petit fragment de de crâne
et de peau fait toujours ça et on le
fait toujours oui oui quand c'est quand
ça grigote donc vraisablement c'est vous
voyez la personne a survécu quand même
assez longtemps assez longtemps c'est
génial ce qu'on peut découvrir à partir
de de tout petit bout de tout petit bout
alors comment étaent préparé les momis
je vais pas vous demander de vous
allonger ici Patrice mais vous voyez ça
c'est vous pourriez ça a été ça a été
testé c'est comme ça oui ça c'est un
c'est là que vous allongez la Mumie ou
alors c'est là que vous l'assayez la
memie c'est un petit peu comme une
chaise percé et la momie pendant
plusieurs mois va être ligotée à une
sorte de fauteuil comme celui-ci ça fait
un peu Harry Potter mais c'est tout à
fait sérieux et la momie va se dessécher
parce que tous ces liquides corporels
vont fuir au fur à mesure être récupérer
dans cette sorte de d'urne et être
ensuite
déposé dans l'église donc elle va se
dessécher progressivement même chose ici
où les fluides vont couler en dessous et
en plus c'est bien ventilèche presque
naturellement presque naturellement en
effet oui oui alors forcément ça dépend
de la complexion de l'individu
c'estàdire de son obésité ou de sa
maigreur des maladies dont il a pu
mourir quelqu'un qui est mort de maladie
infectieuse forcément il va beaucoup
moins bien se conserver que quelqu'un
qui est mort de de cancer par exemple ou
de ou d'un traumatisme qui lu fait
perdre beaucoup de sang écoutez merci
infiniment il faut malheureusement
qu'and on Sarr on pourrait rester des
heures he mais enfin voilà on va inviter
tous les T tous les téléspectateurs tous
les gens à venir voir cette exposition
avec plaisir avec plaisir elle se veut
didactique en tout cas c'est génial
parce qu'on a l'impression de une chance
compliquée qu'on a l'impression de
comprendre grâce à vous merci infiniment
Philippe cherlier merci
beaucoup